good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this evening is mctaggart I
really haven't enjoyed the festival so
far and I can't wait to tell you about
some of the things we've got lined up
tomorrow the commissioning survey is
back and I'm really grateful that all
five controllers for the game agreed to
share discouraged and talk us through
his tears results there was searched
apart around that last year and it
really got me thinking about how good
are we the Indies and say to join
alongside that system this year we've
been also commissioned a survey where
we've asked the fool our community and
the Commission notices what we need ins
are getting right and just as
importantly what we're getting wrong how
to your letter my midi is tomorrow
morning at to mine in the session i'm
really looking forward to there's no
doubt it's been a year of huge change in
tele to me it feels like there's barely
a week for classes when we don't read
about another global deal quite what
that means for BBC quotas and for the
industry as a whole is a session ID
really urge you not to miss that's
tomorrow afternoon in the pentland we've
also have caused got tons and tons of
talent for you to look forward to
tomorrow is actually the 50th
anniversary of match today to the actual
day and gary lineker will be here to
celebrate it back at dynamo is coming
and he's getting performing magic tricks
on you all in his master class and john
bishop will be revealing the winners of
issues Evan Bert Ely award so I really
hope you enjoy the festival tomorrow and
it gives me a great pleasure to welcome
Delaney who's here to introduce this
evening's mctaggart
you know I asked Melanie to be this
year's advisory chair in circumstances
that really do me no credit we were at a
party in a field and she was very merry
and I was fairly sure that she wouldn't
be able to run away and probably just to
get rid of me she said yes but to her
great credit when she sobered up in the
morning she still said yes and she's
done a brilliant job I warned her that
something was bound to happen to her in
the year that she did the festival it
always seems to happen to the Advisory
chairs it happened to me happen to the
last three advisory chairs of this
festival and indeed she has taken on a
new super-sized role as the tea fix exit
of the t4 group a much larger
organization now than it was a year ago
but she's done it all with the kind of
tireless energy that leads the rest of
us exhausted and so the big thanks to
her I've been in the executive chair of
this festival for four years and this is
my last festival and my last book Tigers
thank you I've been occurring to
Edinburgh for many years and probably
still will come to Edinburgh for many
years because of the thing about it is
there's nothing like this where else
would you find it Stephane DOM from
goggle box rubbing shoulders with the
Minister for culture faz actually that
sounds like some weird kind of swingers
party and all keith lemon go through the
controller's keyhole I'm getting tied up
in Stuart Murphy's bedroom doesn't have
much better but i think it was also the
place where the fiercest debates about
the future of our own industry take
notes and many policies and reversals of
policies have come out of this festival
it's also of course a charity and we
provide training for people who are just
about to start out in television at a
time when there's precious little
training left in the industry so it's
been a real privilege to be here
executive chair and I must say thanks to
my executive committee most of whom have
been with me for the entire four
years and to Louise annalisa my two
festival directors as a full-time team
and someone who usually remains hidden
and the technical production of this
festival the found the vision the
management of the rooms of the crews
have been running with ruthless
efficiency by one person for the last
five years and that person is of course
his woman and her name is Nicky Clark
and she has done a fantastic job and go
I'm very glad to say the next executive
chair of this festival is going to be
someone who's long been a supporter and
a loyal friend of the festival and of me
and that's for sure I know he'll do a
brilliant job and I couldn't be more
pleased but he'll be stepping into my
shoes although for the MacTaggart labia
this year's mctaggart speaker is David
Abraham the chief executive of channel 4
david has previously worked at discovery
both here in the UK and in the US where
he was president and general manager of
the US cable network TLC and before
joining trouble for in 2010 he works at
UK TV when he oversaw the rebranding of
its channels alibi yesterday Blighty and
the launch at Dave where he championed
commissions like red dwarf and in the
land of the free and as you might guess
from those distinctive channel Brown
name's David began his career in
advertising at the age of 32 he became
one of the founders of the independent
creative agency sent loose so Luke's
name dog to the patron saint of
creativity was established as an
advertising agency with an unethical and
facial countenance was initiative
initially set up with low hierarchy no
real fixed working hours no fixed desks
people working at the BBC might
recognize this it was found to be
unworkable looks at newks as well
apparently
there's a book about the founding of
salutes and in it there's a story about
a staff meeting where everyone was
encouraged to air any concerns they
might have even those who are unused to
public speaking and because David was
used to public speaking he made himself
uncomfortable apparently by stripping
off well I'm glad to say or maybe a bit
sorry to say that he's here fully
clothed and fairly smartly dressed David
is the sixth chief executive in Channel
Four's history and we haven't heard like
target speaker from channel 4 in 12
years there's a lot to talk about ladies
and gentlemen please welcome this year's
mctaggart speaker david abraham
well thank you very much alone for that
that introduction and to Mel and the
festival committee for inviting me to
give the MacTaggart lecture this year it
really is a tremendous honor to be
speaking both personally and on behalf
of channel for now at around the time
that i started to to think about this
speech i went to see mike leigh's
forthcoming film mr Turner about the
great 19th century British artist it's a
fantastic film I think it's going to be
one of my creative highlights of the
year it also helped me to clarify what I
wanted to talk about today because the
film is a kind of love poem to a strand
of independent British creativity it
tells the story of Turner's later life
how he kept evolving his art to the very
end how we dealt with his critics and
his admirers and how his art helped to
change the way that we all see the world
Turner is played by Timothy Spall
brilliantly as a complex creative soul
he's prickly he's obsessive but he's
deeply human there was one particular
scene that really made an impression on
me Turner's living in his large house
and Chelsea late in his life he's
surrounded by dozens and dozens of his
paintings he's visited by a tycoon the
title walked into the house and
literally pulls out awarded five-pound
notes and says he's good at offer him a
fortune a hundred thousand pounds to buy
all the remaining paintings in the
collection Turner looks up politely and
in declines that the High King says why
and turner says because these paintings
have been bequeathed to whom asked for
tycoon and turn our answers to the
British people to be enjoyed all
together in one place forever and for
free now I think this scene brings out
some quite
flex feelings that many of us have
probably share we want to do work the
pans individual rewards but also work
that matters and is recognized at a
collective level Turner did not die call
he did well from his art but he also
valid it for something more than money
so this movie really pointed me towards
the theme of this mctaggart because we
do indeed still possess in this country
and in this industry are unique and a
precious balance between the collective
and the commercial value of the work
that we do I think it's something to be
proud of not ashamed of and it's
definitely something worth preserving
now a film for brilliantly led of course
by Tessa Ross who's speaking here at the
festival tomorrow before going off to
run the National Theatre is it a
co-producer of mr Turner and when I
spoke to Mike Lee he explained that
months of early development were
required without a script in
collaboration between his cast art
historians and painters full for paid
for that development with what at the
times very little clarity about the
shape of the project Mike's explanation
was film for in a nutshell backing
original hunches from talented people
that go on to challenge and inspire the
public and the high film for lies the
channel 4 corporation a globally unique
phenomenon a publicly owned but
independent institution that pays its
own way with a formal remit to innovate
and to financed in the pender that
producers to take creative risks so here
we have a film about an independent risk
taking artist made by an independent
risk taking director developed by an
independent risk taking film company and
backed by an independent risk
broadcaster now how great how rare and
how bloody British is that in preparing
a speech I've also barely looking back
on my own working life you've heard a
bit about it already there's a strong
thread I've always admired and a greatly
enjoyed supporting people who repeatedly
almost obsessively take on the challenge
that pursue new creative ideas it's an
activity that I've been lucky to
practice on two continents and in three
media advertising television and film
standing up for creative risks in the
commercial world is essentially the way
that I've earned my living for the past
30 years I've always worked at companies
where we believe that an original idea
will outshine a predictable one in the
end and that it can make up for not
having the biggest budget as well such
work which is desirably difficult
creates its own rewards when I graduated
I intended to become a documentary
producers but I have to be honest I
failed to secure the basic training that
I need i was actually rejected by
middlesex Polytechnic I've still got the
the rejection letter on my on my toilet
door at home no matter a friend of mine
suggested advertising as a good
alternative path in its the craters
world and so it proved a really great
environment in which to learn how to
develop ideas would impact in my very
first job in advertising in your
nineteen eighties when characters like
Don Draper really were still in charge I
was told in all seriousness to actually
not even come back to the office unless
the creative work was sold to the client
unchanged and this written character for
me since then I found myself in some
pretty interesting situations like when
my American bosses took a very dim view
when
I ran a 10 part series on discovery
channel about the science of sex and I
promoted it a very big poster campaign
that explained it would be not very
stimulating well when I notice is the
look of regret on the faces of the boar
WKTV in my very first meeting and I told
them on my plans to launch a TV channel
and name it after myself when Louise
Mensch remember her she had dragged me
in a select committee for daring to
defend the satire of Frankie Boyle he
need should my jobs the craters bit and
a money-making bit and the relationship
between to have worked in subtly
different ways as a co-founder of an ad
agency in 1990s it was just about using
great ideas at first to survive as an
independent business and then to grow a
discovery is about developing a global
brand that stood for quality and
maximizing its value to paying
subscribers and a UK TV it was about
balancing the duties of the BBC with the
needs of private joint venture partners
in each of these situations I was able
to observe and learn how differently
creativity can be valued fear and ablame
for example are both poison to healthy
creative environments also different
attitudes toward experimentation and
created with taking do separate our
culture from that of Corporate America a
channel for I have always believed that
defending a tradition of freedom to push
traitors boundaries in an atmosphere of
constructive criticism and support is
the number one requirement of a job now
in recent years we've seen a parade of
Americans standing up here at the
MacTaggart telling us how things ought
to be done but how do you explain the
number of us entities queuing up to buy
our producers and now our broadcasters
doesn't this suggest that maybe as with
our gun laws in our health system it's
us who are showing their
how things ought to be done I believe
it's the brilliance of how we in this
country have balanced private and public
risk-taking but a set free the
creativity and talent that the Americans
are so keen to be invested with a
netflix for example of border show about
a murderous politician who broke the
fourth wall of TV drama had the BBC not
taken that risky decision decades before
my point is not to wrap ourselves now in
a union jack or a saltire it's about
focusing now on the very principles
which you've created much of this
economic value in the first place and
about us doing the hard thinking now
about how to maintain and grow that
system in a world that's got bigger and
much more consolidated now 2014 it just
could be going down as the peak year in
the gold rush of British television in
just a few months we've seen a state of
deals that will reshape our industry in
altar where decisions get made and by
whom diversity of ownership on both of
supply and the buying side of our
industry is reducing rapidly
consolidation is driving ever bigger
bets our free-to-air channels have
become the must have accessories the
tiny dose of 2014 amongst us media
companies eager to stay ahead of each
other by internationalizing their
revenues priming our distribution pipes
and of course shielding their tax
exposure so channel 5 now takes its
orders from Viacom in New York Liberty
and other us shareholders are trying to
play footsie with ITV now this is diff
eventually put Britain's largest
commercial channel in the hands of dr.
John Malone resident at the Colorado who
also now controls the UK's cable pattern
gmedia our largest producer all three
and discovery now incidentally and in
the interests of widening our pool of
mctaggart bogeymen he's also understood
to be the largest landowner in America
he was nicknamed by Al Gore as Darth
Vader he holds net death in his business
of 41 billion dollars and he's quite
well known for not liking to pay tax now
it may be on hold for now but if Fox
Time Warner shying end them all all were
to have merged might still happen
however because that would subsume star
Europe presumably all taking sensitive
nuanced direction from a murder in New
York by the way that entity would have
combined revenues three and a half times
the size of the entire UK television
industry just think about that for them
TV is clearly now a combat vehicle for
tech and mobile companies and platforms
to compete with each other rather than a
sovereign industry in its own right an
apple Disney merger would substantially
dwarf Fox Warner style but what duties
are obligations will these new global
gated communities have towards our
industry whose future very increasingly
influenced what level of accountability
and responsibility are we prepared to
expect from platforms that operate
across technical and geographical
boundaries and how could we expect
people whose idea of a of a good time is
a is a 24-hour kodathoor to understand
the needs of the UK television audience
our independent sector built up and
nurtured over decades is being snapped
up almost wholesale and acquired by
global networks and sold by private
equity investors at a faster rate than
tickets to a public flogging of Jeremy
Clarkson several owners has admitted to
me privately than England they as they
sell cannot fully understand the
thinking behind how their companies are
actually valued it's estimated that the
proportion of turnover of UK production
that will qualify as independent will
drop from around three quarters to
around a half the term super inna d has
in effect become redundant they're just
now Indies and there are studios the
truth is that UK production has turned
in 20 years from an ugly duckling into a
very valuable goose indeed one that as a
result of hard work and a talent has
laid some very valuable golden eggs but
while recognizing how powerful and
desirable the world force UK production
has to come I want to use my speech
today to make it to crucial points
firstly we might just be kidding
ourselves as we think that all this
happened by hard work and its halland
alone the flowering of UK companies to
push creative boundaries have been made
possible by and likened politicians and
regulators bat by huge public support
that's the remarkable thing their wisdom
and foresight has created our unique PSP
system with its plurality of
organizations and owners and its variety
of missions and business models it's
also a settlement through which
broadcasters are incentivized to create
public service content with the carrot
of prominence and access to the airwaves
at the center of this of course is the
BBC funded by the licence fee and we
hear a lot from those who would did it
down and maybe it should be taking more
risks and rattling more cages yet when
you ask the public it's one of the
best-loved brands in the country and
it's seen as a good value for money it
has its contradictions yes but there's
always much to admire my second point is
that the system now risks becoming a
victim of its own success while UK
production is an undoubted commercial
success
success story I wonder if it will
continue to be a creative one scale
demands an increased focus on
cost-cutting and margins reformatting of
ideas is more efficient than the messy
business of finding new ones fear of
risk can overtake an appetite for it
will in the next generation of TV execs
in this room have the same opportunities
as the last or will it be so starved of
quality scripts that will have to submit
their own police dramas on the janitor
reverse pseudonyms like Ruby Solomon for
example I'm looking forward to the
series and what about those of you who
don't plan to get rich just have a quite
reasonable expectation of working in a
vibrant industry and doing interesting
and original work now in addition to the
uncertainty that all these deals create
my belief is that much of the value of
the companies that have been bought has
depended on creative freedom and
independence this in turn blossomed
enlarged reservoirs of creative risk
capital creative competition has driven
innovation all to the benefit of the UK
viewer now the PSP is of course aren't
deep many broadcasters to invest in UK
content however a look at the numbers
alone shows who really takes more risks
although total pt's pay TV revenues in
the UK dwarf those of the PSD sector
eighty percent of the 1.7 billion spent
on original commissions from UK
producers in 2013 came from the PS fees
the other twenty percent of it 380
1,000,000 went to UK in these from
multi-channel players in total meanwhile
sky gave back 715 million pounds to its
shareholders in the last financial year
channel 4 is different although also
commercially funded it's a
not-for-profit organization this means
we spend our revenues on stream rather
than on shareholders and as a publisher
broadcaster we can and we do spend the
majority of that with the UK producers
but let's imagine for a moment what a
profit maximizing channel 4 would look
like to deliver say a twenty percent
margin I take fewer greatest risks with
far fewer companies I would push out
positions repeats and add funded
programs and I've minimized public
service obligations as ITV and Channel
five have done over the years I have to
take a load of production in-house
obviously but isn't that what viewers
producers and advertisers really want
I'm quite sure my shareholders have
wanted all done quicker than you could
say dick adjacent channel 4 has a great
brand heritage and so some viewers it
might not notice through a bit but
pretty fast they wake up and they
realized Britain had another channel 5 I
knew the channel 5 got me there
in Britain we value some things beyond
money alone just to turn a dude that's
always been true in the field of culture
and it's true in other areas as well for
example when Pfizer made it recent bid
for AstraZeneca concern rapidly
crystallized around the risk to the UK's
pharmaceutical research and development
base astrazeneca kisses British company
that invests heavily in rd here they
support a research base both private and
embedded in a raft of university
research departments which pulls through
the generations of scientists following
behind by the way most of them were
probably cruelly rejected by Middlesex
toilet technique once lost it's almost
impossible to replace channel 4 into the
UK's increasingly precious example of
this in television supporting over 350
companies across the UK generating over
25,000 jobs and driving a significant
proportion of the export value of our
entire creative industries and as is
evident from the current challenges of
local television building new
sustainable models that deliver public
purposes is incredibly hard and it's
incredibly rare talking of which London
alive Wow a television channel dedicated
to the most vibrant city on earth with
fewer viewers than a Poldark rerun now
in the weeks ahead we'll be publishing a
report looking at channel forces
risk-taking role in television and one
of the many things it looks at is the
government's approach to stimulate an
R&D and innovation across all industries
the conclusion if you didn't have a
channel for in the creative industries
already the strategy would probably lead
you to create one my personal experience
over the past four years has been that
the UK government is a wise owner
channel 4 it does not interfere with its
editorially oversight is delegated off
from and their appointed chair and on
exec director the system works in short
we believe in our not-for-profit model
most of all we believe in our unique
public service agreement given to us by
Parliament to be innovative to be
distinctive or to put it another way to
take creative risks that gave us
trainspotting GBH to Desmond's brass I
big breakfast allergy Channel 4 News and
dispatchers today it's still giving
Black Mirror educating Yorkshire the
last leg the undateable is complicit 12
years a slave and yes Channel 4 News and
dispatches for me to have been part of
the 2012 Paralympic Games was
extraordinary it changed forever the way
that I see the world and it tells me
that the remit is as relevant and it's
necessary now as it's ever been even in
a world of hundreds of homogenous
channels and the internet times change
and roles changed and back in the house
in days of four or five channels yes I
can see the mist forming in your eyes up
there in the back road channel 4 was the
alternative with a capital A yes we're
still here to keep the BBC on its toes
the BBC Trust says we're doing that
pretty well in current affairs at the
moment for example and that will always
be part of what channel 4 is 4 but we
also now have a role at the front edge
of the mainstream giving the whole
nation new ways of seeing the world ways
of challenging rather than familiar
contemporary / nostalgic and popular
rather than niche what really struck me
about benefit Street was the waiting
engage so deeply on the right and on the
left of politics but with mass audiences
at the same time so I now like to give
you a short break and a break with the
traditions of this lecture this is a
channel for TB events after all and show
you a
piece of inspiring channel for
creativity it's made by our in-house
creative team were brilliant and who are
led by Dan bro if Abbott Rises the
difficult fake it was incredible about
the taste another voice there and it's
gone now
to love is to disappear in the phone to
be addressed because Santa Marta
to recharge for another is to risk a
moment to explore feelings of distress
exposing yourself bless eid is your
dreams in front of a crowd history's
being common naive to try to dying
nothing nothing does nothing power thing
because the person who risks
whose parents
to church
now that's work that makes me really
proud and it works delivered one of our
largest award halls ever across multiple
genres and in stronger public approval
of the poor brand that we've seen for
many years and this is the result of the
patience and skill of Jay Hunt and her
team and all the great producers who
work with us when I arrived at horse
free road in 2010 people said that
channel 4 was a busted flush an enormous
Big Brother shape sinkhole in the
schedule and an empty begging bowl in
the boardroom but for the past four
years we've kept our annual revenues
above 900 million a year throughout a
long recession and we have nurtured our
reserves we've been spending record
amounts on UK content with a very wide
range of enemies and after a period of
investing we'll be back in surplus this
year channel for now is now up in peak
and portfolio 16 to 30 for share is the
highest it's been for a decade or more
most of our best rating shows a new ones
and we have strong commercial
partnerships with UK TV and BT sport now
who would have bet on all of that when a
big brother ended looking back perhaps I
underestimated the time it takes to
replace franchises on a terrestrial
channel it took my TV time to build
their audiences back up and fair play
today on their success but Jay and I are
also persistent while aiming to be
different too we've shown we can deliver
the remit with impact and without public
money for programs and we'll carry on
doing it even as we evolved creatively
and digitally now over the past few
years I've been encouraging the TV
industry to embrace the power of data
for example i hold all i hope some of
you impressed i think that's is with 20
minutes before i mentioned d
a TV channel without a data strategy is
like a submarine without sonar and 11
million people have now signed up to
four including half of all 16 to 24 year
olds what's the point well we can
personalize which works for viewers and
advertisers and it means we pay for even
more programs control of data also helps
to fight off those who would burgle the
relationship that our viewers have with
our brands and many of your productions
this is how we will all have to compete
in the future or you could as a producer
invest your own money in your own
content and then share almost half the
income with YouTube for example well
good luck with that model everyone we
were innovators with 40 d but our
strategy is now evolving we think that
when broadcasters separate online brands
from channel brands they end up doing
splits we also think the future is not
about either the decline of linear and
the rise of on-demand it will be about
the blend of both using the strengths of
each so from next year we will
seamlessly unite all of our channels and
services in one place in the online
world it will be an elegant design
solution to a knotty problem that I
think the whole industry is facing and
this process of change has shown us what
we knew instinctively that it's also
time to change how we think about our
public service delivery judging it via
channel 4 alone just doesn't make sense
any longer it's our log thinking in a
world that's gone digital we've gone
some way down the road
industry-recognized but we want it to go
a lot further so we'll be talking to
Ofcom about that in a forthcoming PST
review after all it wasn't just channel
4 but our entire digital estate that
delivered the power of the paralympics
soon we will do the same with brilliant
new dramas from Russell T Davies
cucumber banana and tofu telling
overlapping stories of different
generations of gay people in Britain
today now that just would not have been
possible back in the day of queer as
folk we're constantly changing the ways
in which we reach our audience by short
form for example which we adjust ramped
up or on e4 young people now the most
diverse group in the UK see it as a
terrestrial channel for them so we'll
invest further in e for next year which
is good for them and good for the PSP
system not least because there's
radioactive waste stored 2 miles
underground buried less thoroughly than
BBC three be so at four we plan to keep
pushing ahead and keep delivering and we
need new freedoms to keep experimenting
but we're being asked by regulators and
stakeholders have them the whole system
of which we're part the public service
broadcasting system be strengthened even
further and help create new jobs new
ideas you thinking for the future of the
UK indeed up at least once a decade
we've returned here to Edinburgh to this
most central of questions what is the
best way to organize ourselves so as to
maximize the greatest potential of this
medium in this country and in accordance
with our national appetite for creative
and distinctive British content the more
UK content creation is the better
everyone wins and it's equally clear
that the PS fees are the most effective
at delivering it we spending much more
across more genres with more certainty
we also take many more creative risks
it's baked into our numerical
obligations but it's also hardwired into
who we are recent government measures
have focused on tax breaks to support
any good investment for production in
the UK but bringing American movie and
drama productions here is great for jobs
in the same way as making iPhones in
China is great for China but the IP and
a profits well there on the first boat
out of here in contrast PSP investment
is the nation
investment based on our spectrum and to
broadcasters that we the public own out
right with the next ps3 review in the
next chart around we have a critical
opportunity to update the ps3 settlement
for a new era to strengthen it and to
help the whole UK creative economy to
continue to grow today I'd like to talk
about two areas that we believe can make
a real difference and there's only time
to set out some broad principles don't
worry SI unit will be hearing in the Q&A
to explain the detail to everyone
including me the first is a fair deal on
platform relations many parts of the
television ecosystem benefit from the
PSP's huge investment in content
including pay TV platforms which
generated 5.9 billion pounds last year
in subscription revenues from UK
households these saying households spend
on average more time watching the box
than anything else they do in their
large apart from sleeping and working
and in total more of that time is spent
watching the PSB channels than any other
so I think it's reasonable to say that
pay-tv subscribers like what we do which
is presumably why pay platforms or ready
paying us for valuable services like
equal HD and 40 D so let's consider a
simple question how much do you think
the pay TV platforms pay for the most
popular services the core PSP shows well
I'll tell you 0 in fact it's worse than
that with Sky the PSP still have to pay
unless we trade valuable services in
return it's just bizarre isn't it it
undervalues the UK creative economy of
which we are all past and that simply
cannot be right it's certainly not
considered right in other countries no
in fact the UK is now one of the few
major markets in the world where public
service broadcasters received no payment
for the immense value that
channels bring to pay platforms now is
the time to correct this and we need new
rules to do it while you're regulation
why couldn't it just be an open
negotiation between the two parties no
pay no play the problem with this is
that there's an imbalance in the scale
obligations and incentives on each side
of the table more significantly at
channel 4 we faced a strong constraint
in terms of our responsibility to the
public not to withdraw our services from
platforms our unique remix set out in
legislation together with our duty to be
universally available would undermine
what in a commercial world would be a
straight arm wrestle this is why we need
regulation at a minimum to act as a
backstop if the parties cannot reach an
independent agreement and I look forward
to discussing this with Ofcom and the
government in the months ahead and I
commit here and now here in Edinburgh
that every single penny of a fair deal
on platform relations that came out of
these negotiations would be spent on
commissioning more UK original content
with UK producers the second area is a
fair deal on terms of trade now at
channel 4 will be proud to have been a
key player in developing the UK energy
sector and we want to continue to see it
growing by ensuring fair values returned
to producers for creative endeavor but
as Tony Hall recently pointed out the
old settlement on terms of trade
reflected the markets of the time an
absence of competition strong
broadcasters weakening these fledgling
cable and satellite companies today if
danny cowan thinks that the BBC is
dwarfed by the major studios can you
imagine how the world looks from my
office we agree that it is the right
time to sit back and to reset to ask
ourselves questions now about what form
our relationship with the producers
should take in doing so we would start
from four basic
source firstly we don't intend to follow
others and set up in-house production so
breathe easy everyone that's one less
thing to worry about secondly that the
health and diversity of the indie sector
is critical to channel 4 because of our
reliance on it for our lifeblood thirdly
smaller companies need a special level
of support and protection when
participating in a market characterized
by big players many of whom are
connected to broadcasters especially
when another big beast BBC production
limited is poised to enter accompanied
by the BBC's call for a level playing
field incidentally when I ran till see
my biggest producer with BBC productions
in New York and I think it would be a
mistake to underestimate them fourthly
and finally as the market changes around
us flexibility to evolve our deal terms
is becoming increasingly important for
the future of for we are looking for a
regime that allows us to make the best
of the opportunity to innovate new
digital services this benefits audiences
and advertisers and also allows us to
earn a fair return on the risk capital
that we invest in developing
commissioning and marketing news shows
so we will look to Ofcom to devise
measures for a healthy and diverse
market for program supply in the future
many things won't need to be changed at
all for example the presumption that
Indies will own the copyright in
programs and control having to national
distribution is managed some of the
things that we envisage in a package of
support for smaller companies may even
represent a more favorable position than
exists today other parts of our
arrangements will also change for
example in how we make sure that we
don't let old definitions the primary
and secondary rights get in the way of
delivering what we need for advertisers
and
this is in the UK all of this is
designed to grow the total commercial
value available and share that value
fairly this enables us to spend as much
as we possibly can investing in new
content in our directly into creative
individuals as well in my experience the
most creative people would rather stay
independent for as long as possible even
if they do have an eye long-term on the
exit freedom combined with hunger drives
creativity but in a time ambitious
companies also realize the need for
capital to expand internationally or
beyond a single genre for example the
new channel for Growth Fund is a
much-needed facilitator for this stage
in the development of great companies
our investees remaining completely
control of their own destinies and a
free to act independently on
distribution they're also free to work
with whomever they like as well without
output deals titleist now I began today
by talking about our independent
tradition a British creativity so I now
on to bring this back to some of the
creative people who generate new ideas
in our industry today the first people
channel 4 is backing directly with the
growth fund this is Colin Moxon Rory
wheeler and Emma Pierce they want
popcorn a new company doing a great
documentary sing some great branded
content and we're going to be working
with them and helping them expand their
business and to develop creatively and
commercially this is andrew sheldon just
fouled and Mark Allen and over the last
few years they've been building a true
north into a highly respected regional
ending based in Leeds they're now in
partnership with channel forth with the
Growth Fund and are looking to expand
both in terms of their international
footprint and in terms
there's honors to John Smithson he
impelling and Tom brizzly they've been
doing some of the best specialists fact
of programming in the world over the
last few decades recently they formed an
arrow and they're now working with us on
expanding their business in the future
Simon Chinn is a london-based
oscar-winning documentary producer we
set up lightbox with Jonathan gym in los
angeles they already have Series in
production in America and in a viterbi
expanding in partnership with the Growth
Fund so this is a very exciting but just
first wave of a great British trated
talent backed by the fund what we will
do is help support their growth over
time and redirect all the future returns
back into even making more programs or
investing in new companies it's as
simple as that and as part of our wider
contribution to the diversity the
British television expect to see
companies in the nation's and companies
led by baap talent receiving serious
investments from the channel for Growth
Fund as well to support such companies
would be a fantastic legacy of the fund
which brings me to the other deal word
diversity and I speak here as someone
whose parents came to this country in
the 1950s and I know that this country
has given me many great opportunities a
channel for we've had many diversity
firsts the first black sitcom the first
lesbian kiss the first disabled and
transgender winners of mainstream
entertainment shows and the first
portrayal of Paralympians as superhuman
these symbolic game changes has have
transformed the psyche of our nation but
not of our industry I fear as a board
member of creative skillset I'm as
concerned as anyone that the number of
people from ethnic minorities working in
television
I've been falling this isn't just a
failure retention it's a collective
failure to grow our talent pool when we
get things right the results are
spectacular Britain's Steve McQueen
becoming the first clap director to win
the Best Picture Oscar it just wasn't a
triumph only a cinematic art it was a
triumph of imagination over business as
usual and a moment has come thanks to
Lenny Henry and many others where we all
agree that it's time for change from
surgeon and collective change one big
step has been a successful creative
industries bid for government co-funding
into skills that channel 4 has recently
supported this will help to create many
new opportunities and develop the
careers of thousands of people over the
next few years at entry level and
equally importantly all the way through
to leadership I also fully support the
joined up industry approached at the CDN
under Adam prozis leadership has
recently set out next year through the
new silver mouse monitoring system we
will finally know continuously and
exactly who is on British television and
who makes it the lights will go on and
when people see more clearly they think
more clearly they become more conscious
of unconscious bias and minds will open
up to new creative possibilities we also
like the BFI street if initiative and
we're developing a similar approach for
television we'll be announcing our own
set of detailed proposals this autumn
aimed at encouraging our commissioners
and producers to think even more
imaginative leading about creative
decisions across multiple aspects of
diversity and multiple genres in the
meantime let me be clear a successful
diversity strategy is about increasing
not limiting creative freedom it's about
nurturing a new talent and giving voice
to untold stories what we all need now
is joined up ashen across our industry
and that's why I'm so determined to work
with my
fellow CEOs to push this mission across
broadcasting
so
we are a great creative nation we drive
in our unique climate of creative
freedom and risk-taking we prize money
yes but something bigger to something
that feels not just pockets but the
millions of hearts and minds as well
just as Turner did almost 200 years ago
I see that spirit alive today here in
this room and i'm proud to be part of it
as the great inventions of john logie
baird and tim berners-lee converge
another great invention of ours the
public service broadcasting system has
created the best conditions for creative
program making on this planet it has
helped to turn the content we all create
into gold the world is rushing in and
that's wonderful but a word of warning
this special landscape of ours did not
as I have said happen by accident we
should not assume that left purely to
the market it will continue to thrive to
keep the ps3 system growing we need to
nurture not neglect it today I've set
out ways in which we channel for are
doing that but we aren't doing it alone
no one single person or company can we
need politicians and we need regulators
to act they've done it before and they
must do it again or the public will not
thank them so I call on them to act and
to act decisively update and strengthen
the ps3 system the system that is
delivered so spectacularly for UK
viewers and for UK plc and I call on you
to do everything you can to persuade
them if you care about creativity speak
up and speak up now stay silent and our
special system may wither once gone it
will never come back this TV festival is
a wonderful showcase for the very best
creative ideas teams and skills that we
have to offer today and its best it's
where the most important debates to get
about what we value and
where we are heading next so I urge you
let's have this debate and let's have it
right now to paraphrase Madeleine
Albright there's a special place
reserved in hell for those who succeed
and don't put down a ladder but those
coming behind them so let us avoid any
risk that someone in a suit might look
back from this podium in a decade or so
and say that the end of the story began
here let's not miss the signs or screw
up the system let's make damn sure that
we nurture the potential of everyone
here who is under the age of 30 you are
televisions Turner's of tomorrow the
future of Great British creativity thank